did you hurt someone
yes
very good
Billy eilish makes her acting debut I'm
a speechless over a year after hosting
Saturday Night Live we put the hospital
in Hospitality
Billy's doing drama in the Prime video
series swarm name Kayla name Dre good
tell me something you regret I hear it's
dark I hear it's sexy I hear it's scary
this is also comedic people are thinking
it's one thing but I find when they see
it it'll be completely different than
what we thought
I see
milk spilled on the carpet
what color was the milk
did you hurt someone
yes
very good
details about the Grammy winners role
are Hush Hush for now but there's no
mystery behind Billy's casting the main
character is described as an obsessed
fan of the world's biggest pop star
finger but she doesn't necessarily seem
like a happier than ever fan she's not
like everybody else we're told the
series takes inspiration from multiple
real life music icons but there's
speculation that one artist Reigns
Supreme
yeah there's no denying the similarities
here with Beyonce her fan base The
Beehive this series title swarm are you
still Tweeting from that old ass phone
account she knows what we're thinking
and she gives it a name she's a goddess
ah it's not Loosely based on Beyonce
it's a amalgamation of of different
celebrities and our current climate
being kind of uh intense about our love
for celebrities and everybody loves
Beyonce so it's easy to to correlate the
tube oh it's easy the show's co-creator
is Beyonce's Lion King co-star Donald
Glover oh yeah Beyonce is in it another
connection Chloe Bailey who along with
her sister Halle Bailey was discovered
by Queen Bee you're gonna see that it
takes his own world in his own journey I
feel like every episode is going to keep
you on your toes and one and more
between the Beyonce Vibes and Billy's
acting debut we're sure stands of both
will be swarming when the show premieres
March 17th
I see
milk spilled on the carpet
what color was the milk
did you hurt someone
yes
very good
[Music]